[Music]
morning it's early wait I only have 20
minute oh there we go okay I got scared
good morning super excited to be here a
really really fun to be here so what do
I want to talk about so look I think
there's a lot of things going on and I
feel an enormous kinship to this
audience I think through my career over
the last 10 years I've spent a lot of
time interacting engaging with have a
lot of friends in this industry and I
think it's been really interesting for
me to watch this space evolve over the
last decade I think I spoke at this
event maybe eight years ago or something
of that nature and back then it was like
hey there's technology and there's these
things like Google AdWords and Twitter
and things of that nature and clearly
we've evolved in a very big way from
there you know I think what I want to
really talk about today is a couple of
core things a attention I think the one
thing that binds everybody in this room
depending on how much business they're
doing what market they're in how long
they've been in the industry how they
roll hold on real quick is that a Jets
Jersey I love you
uh the one thing that 100% binds all of
you is that before you tell me how great
this house is or this property is or how
great you are we are all battling in
this room for attention and attention is
fickle and attention moves and that has
basically been my career my career has
been predicated on what I call day
trading attention I want to know where
people are and I want to figure out how
to story tell to them in that medium
right and if that meant billboards
because people drove and continued to
great if that means Direct Mail because
people were going through their mail
very carefully and aggressively in the
60s 70s 80s 90s great and then for me as
some of you know that became the
Internet itself and so I launched an
e-commerce website in the wine business
in 1997 long before people believed that
people would buy wine through the
internet I think for how many people
here by show of hands have made an
Instagram story already raise your hands
you know so for you know about 30 or 40
of you you know that attention can shift
in minutes right 48 hours ago 72 hours
ago there is no Instagram stories people
trying to figure out their snapchat
strategies I see a lot of snapchat
shirts in the crowd and so these are
things you know snapchat or Instagram
stories is not something that I would
have even been able to reference at this
conference a year ago with any
seriousness its snapshots something I've
been paying attention to and so that's
basically the punchline the punchline is
what what are you doing in a 20-17
environment that's actually going to
help you sell more homes bring more
awareness build your business build your
brand what are those strategies what are
those implications here's what I want to
establish right away this morning which
is a we are living through the single
biggest communication shift that we've
lived through since the printing press
the first thing you have to really wrap
your head around in this room this
morning is how substantial the culture
shift really is I think the biggest
thing that I'm fascinated by is that
every single person in this room
including myself is grossly under
estimating how big of a ship this is if
you were just sitting in my shoes right
now you would realize there's about 90
people right now holding up a cell phone
recording this talk this is you haven't
understand how interesting that is
because 10 years ago we didn't even have
smartphones right we're definitely not
recording content at scale at scale
we're producing content at a level we've
never seen before and so what that means
to everybody in this room is something
very interesting here's what it means we
have a massive supply and demand issue
you're trying to get somebody's
attention for what you're trying to sell
them the problem is that end-user is
getting pounded with 500 10,000 times
the amount of content that they did just
10 years ago and so how are you going to
break through that environment because
it's not just if they're in the market
to buy a new home it's every product and
service that they are trying to achieve
in their lives and to me that is a
fascinating fascinating supply and
demand issue that every single person in
this room is dealing with so how do you
break through what do you do I think
what you first have to do is recognize
that attention is driving very very
quickly I think the biggest thing that
concerns me this morning more than
anything is have you become complacent
or romantic about what's working for
your business now the biggest thing that
I'm fascinated by is when something
works for somebody do they try to milk
it forever and hope nothing changes a
lot of you know a lot of you in this
room know that Twitter was my coming-out
party in the digital world I invested in
it
I became big on it I amassed a million
followers on it it is devastating to me
that Twitter does not hold the attention
that it once did six or seven years ago
I spent every single hour between 7 p.m.
and 2:00 in the morning from 2007 to
2011 in my life to a mass an audience on
Twitter but in 2011 when I started
noticing that even though I had 800
thousand followers and I was posting
something that I was not getting the
same results that I was when I had
50,000 followers that became the moment
that I instead of what most people do
which is desperately try to hold on put
my head in the sand or what a lot of
people's strategy is in this room on
digital ships which is hope [ __ ] hope
that everything's gonna be okay what I
started doing in 2011 was I started
investing a lot more time and energy in
figuring out Instagram in 2012 and 13 in
figuring out snapchat I spent a lot of
time on things that didn't work out
Socialcam became something I spent a lot
of time in in 2012 vine became something
I spent a lot of time in 2014
Pinterest is something I spent a lot of
time in 2012 13 14 right tumblr was
something I spent a lot of time on so
they're not all wins but the biggest
thing that I could leave you with in
this room and again there's been a
dramatic knowledge gained in this
collective room even getting ready for
this talk looking at your content your
hashtags your tweets it's just such a
higher understanding there's still some
tried-and-true things that are not being
executed last night I stayed in my bed
when I got here late and just went
through a lot of your accounts that
we're using the hashtag or mention game
and I'm just like what's the State of
the Union of the people in the room like
how are they rolling couple things one
unfortunately the last two books before
the askgaryvee book Jab Jab Jab right
hook and the Thank You economy are both
still very underutilized by the market
people continue to put out content that
is in high percentage in their best
interest and not in the value of the end
user I am still baffled by why the real
estate industry on an individual broker
level does not realize that they need to
become the digital mayor of their town
and what I mean by that is the number
one blueprint that fundamentally look
you're gonna be here the whole you know
time and you're gonna get a lot of good
content from a lot of people you're
gonna hear a couple of nuggets from me a
lot of them
move the needle a little bit a lot of
them move the needle a little bit you
might sell to more homes for more homes
to fundamentally change your business
where you go from where you are now to 5
10 20 X the revenue and volume you have
to make dramatic changes and that
dramatic change sits in the form and
here it is here it is and by the way 99
percent of you are not going to do
anything about what I'm about to say I'm
being very honest with you because the
punchline here is it's hard work and the
reality is that a lot of people are just
not willing to put in the work I mean
that's just the fundamental reality and
in fact I always think the digital
excites people because they think it's
scalable they think like all of a sudden
the computers going to do the [ __ ]
work for them right the number one shift
that everybody has to do in this room is
understand the following statement and
understand it cold not just shake your
head when you hear the words coming out
of my mouth the quicker you understand
in this room that you are a media
company comma real estate agent real
estate software provider whatever you
may be I know that I'm a media company
comma an agency CEO a wine retailer once
you make that shift everything changes
for example when you make that mental
shift the content that you put out on
Facebook and Twitter and Pinterest and
Instagram and snapchat fundamentally
changes right now what many of you do
for a living you're forced to be in the
right hook business the hell are you
going to put out content wise right when
you decide to become the digital mayor
of your town everything fundamentally
changes if you decide that you not the
local newspaper is going to be the
provider of the content of the best
restaurants reviewing the school system
and every other milk and cranny in the
two four six and eight towns that you
live in you fundamentally start bringing
value
to end users that are intrigued or
interested into moving into your town I
do not believe that most people sitting
here this morning think that they're
going to be the editor-in-chief of a
newspaper but that is absolutely how I
view every single one of you that you
have the potential to be that content
producer you're filming now you could be
filming a lot of things that actually
bring value to the person that's
debating to go from the city tear
suburbs they are looking for that
information
why can't you you Sally you [ __ ]
Frank you Frank
why can't you why can't you be the
person that interviews the principal of
all the schools why can't you be the
person that writes a review of every
dish of every restaurant of in your town
why can you not be that person that is
my belief that is the wide open white
space for every person in this room that
changes their business because you then
become synonymous with the town you
become the media entity you become the
person that fundamentally has the
attention and what comes out of that and
this is very important to understand is
your ability than to market yourself at
a greater sense because the content is
dramatically dramatically more viral in
the number one platform that everybody
should be spending all their time on
which is Facebook in a world where
everybody is very excited about all the
new things as am i I live and breathe
for it even besides the snapchats of the
world I'm paying attention to anchor and
musically and peach and after-school and
there's plenty of things bubbling up
that I'm curious in two to three years
will matter to you and you can sell from
even in that world we are sitting in a
very interesting time one of the things
that I thought was very fascinating when
I dig a little deep into a lot of the
comments I went back a little bit I was
curious what you guys said
back in November December in January
about the Facebook feed right what did
this collective group think about that
and much to what I thought people were
very upset and complaining right
people were upset that six months ago a
year you lost a lot of your
Janak reach on Facebook it wasn't as
good anymore
sucks [ __ ] you right well what I found
fascinating about that was that in lieu
of that feed organic growth going away
what grew was one of the greatest ad
products of all time if you're sitting
in this room this morning you have a
real career a real business the fact
that most of the people in this room do
not deploy at least $1,000 a month into
a Facebook environment to drive their
business is borderline laughable and in
reality just downright stupid let me
explain why by show of hands how many
people in this room when they watch
television now watch it on their time
not when the actual thing airs but
between DVR Netflix HBO GO besides live
sports and I know it's early in some of
you are lazy but raise your hands
because it's important for everybody how
many people watch TV now on their time
raise your hand good everybody how many
people in this room when given the
chance fast-forward every single
commercial my friends I live in a world
now vaynermedia run a 650 person digital
agency it's a 100 million dollar revenue
business Toyota Unilever Under Armour
you know USA Network's biggest brands in
the world dove the whole nine they spend
ninety billion dollars collectively
making videos and distributing them to
sell you stuff right I live in a world
ride day trade attention every person in
this room and I think we can agree this
is not a fifteen year old girl crowd
right every person this room just raised
their hand that they do not watch
commercials at all costs and even if
even if even if the brand is lucky
enough to get the commercial in front of
you because you dropped your remote
control off your bed
even if that happens every person here
the second that commercial runs grabs
this and you check on your business your
tweet about what LeBron just did you
definitely don't give the attention to
the commercial let me explain why this
matters to this room so much how many
people here in their career did Google
AdWords at some point raise your hands
great very good how many people here and
did Google AdWords back in 2000 one two
and three when I was doing just raise
your hands
uh-huh for the 20 of you you remember
what I remember which was it was a great
[ __ ] deal right when I bought the
word wine the day Google AdWords came
out for five cents a click before Google
raised the minimum I owned it for nine
and a half months before anybody even
bid me up because nobody knew it existed
my career has been about day trading
attention I grew my dad's liquor store
from a three to a sixty million dollar
business in five years because I
launched a website when nobody thought
websites were important how many people
here have done email marketing in their
career raise your hand you're going to
love this one in 1997 I had 150,000 a
200 thousand person email newsletter
that had ninety one percent open rates
yeah not because I was a hero oh by the
way forget about that fifty five percent
click to add to cart within the email
not because I was a hero or I was so
smart
where I wrote such great copy it's
because nobody was email marketing in
1997 who you're at email 97 98 99 raise
your hands do you remember for the
youngsters in this room we read every
[ __ ] word of every email we treated
email like it was regular mail like very
carefully like Dear John yes you know
all of it that same email newsletter
today even after 10 years of money and
strategy and all this is that 33 percent
open rates and that's remarkable and
that's because we consciously put a lot
of effort towards it so that has been my
career what I knew what happened on
Google AdWords is about to happen in
social media and my
let's get this straight in this room
right now there is no social media
social media is a slang term for the
current state of the internet there is
no social media we called it web 2.0 for
all the old G's in this room right there
is no social media social media is a
term we use to talk about Facebook and
Instagram and snapchat we even throw
LinkedIn and YouTube even throw
utilities and content platforms into
social media social media you mean the
thing that we spend 51% of our time on
on this device and if you sit in this
room in late 2016 and you do not
understand
that this is the remote control of our
lives
how many people here in every 24 hour
window are always within arm's reach of
their phone I would literally rather
somebody stab me in the streets of New
York and steal my wallet then lose my
[ __ ] phone attention for example I
today for all my businesses all my
hundred fifty plus investments Wine
Library vaynermedia my personal brand I
don't even think about the internet at
all in any other platform than my mobile
device as a matter of fact I just got my
design team at vaynermedia together last
week and I told them I want to redesign
vaynermedia's website and next month or
so you will go to vaynermedia com and if
you go on it in a laptop environment it
will actually go to a page vaynermedia
com that will say the following it will
look broken and it will say to you hey
jerk its 2017 go get your [ __ ] phone
it will actually not work on a laptop
here's why this is important
I am extremely curious what your
website's how your marketing looks in a
mobile world many people here have been
very smart about their landing page
optimisation about their marketing
material about their
videos that they put on their website
and a lot of them don't even work in
this environment and very quickly within
24 months what is the 20th at the 22nd
anniversary of [ __ ] Inman connect the
entire end consumer that you're trying
to sell to will only be living in this
environment so if you have any call to
action from this talk today please go
home and adjust your web and social
presence only into a mobile-first
environment because there will be
nothing else and a lot of you are
converting great leads and other things
through a desktop world you've got to
make that same commitment to understand
what's happening in here because this is
the punchline this is how you will sell
I've got a friend who in the last four
months has sold four homes through
Facebook live at his open homeless
things from people that didn't show up
to the open house it was just him
walking around with his Facebook live
and he has a very small group of like 50
people watching those Facebook lives but
three of his four transactions were some
one of those 50 sharing it into the
network of their friends and then them
friends becoming aware of it literally I
mean this is what you do for a living
literally selling homes from Facebook
live because he's and think about it you
guys do open houses all the time I
assume you know some of those aren't
well attended sometimes there is some
downtime multiple times you have
multiple people in the home that can one
of them can hold the phone there is real
transactional value going on in this
environment and I'm just thirsty thirsty
for people to understand how big of a
deal it is because of this attention
arbitrage there's so much opportunity
for example best practices I want to get
very detailed here today to be honest
with you Instagram how many people using
Instagram for their business raise your
hand if you were posting content on
Instagram for your business hey anybody
who's not is making a massive mistake
because the attention of 28 to 65 on
Instagram is stunning deep and when you
think about the decision maker in home
transactions
female gateway drug to those
transactions there's enormous attention
as a matter of fact one of the most
interesting
data points right now on Instagram is
the fastest-growing demo of selfies on
Instagram our forty to fifty year old
females literally cooler selfies
literally listen I love it
I'm showing it however one of things I
did last night was I went to four of
yours and I've forged a very small
sample group but I went to four of your
Instagram accounts and looked at the
content many of you posting content
rooms homes information mixing it up I'm
fine with jabbing and the right hooking
but when I look at the posts of them
four people only one of them used a
hashtag and they used one so just to get
to details a I would take it far more
seriously and I would produce a lot more
content on Instagram
B when you post on Instagram for so many
of you you do not have a large audience
for so many of you there's not a lot of
people following you and so for so many
of you I highly highly recommend using
ten fifteen twenty-five hashtags because
if you're sitting here today and you
want to start your Instagram you know
journey the number one way to get
discovered is through tactical hashtag
evolution so please go into that world
understand which hashtags have a lot of
results understand which hashtags don't
have a lot of results where you can pop
out whether it's the name of your towns
or by adding the word house or things of
that nature so much business opportunity
in that environment let's talk about
Facebook again one more time I'm gonna
go back to it because it's super
important one of the things that I'm
stunned by is how unbelievably strong
the ad product really is one of the
things that how many people here have
run Facebook Ads
for their business raise your hand
fantastic so we are deep in here a
couple things one of the things that I
have been fascinated by is Facebook
video content and how it drives down the
cost of conversion on your non video
content so I'm giving you a very
detailed execution here but because so
many of you raised
your hand I'm going to go there one of
the things that is wide open in your
space right now is the following
execution this is kind of how I would
pattern it and I know I'm going way more
detailed in this talk than rah rah you
can do it and I think that's the right
tone
here's we're going open house or you're
gonna list it video content Facebook
live obviously have to get permission
from cell you know you guys figure all
that part out first Facebook live does
that content it's very raw you're
dropping the phone you're walking up the
stairs but when it's done it saves and
it posts you then go into that content
and you edit that video take out parts
of that video 30 seconds here 60 seconds
there 30 seconds here now again some of
you are single practitioners others have
people in their company that can help
them for the people how many people here
if they're gonna do bless you how many
people here if you're going to do
Facebook advertising or video creation
it's going to be on your head you don't
have the overhead or infrastructure and
have somebody else to it raise your
hands
great so that's a lot of you here's a
really important part for a lot of you
for a lot of you you're going to go into
excuse mode right now I don't have the
time I didn't grow up with this a lot
when people come up to me like Gary this
technology I know it's important but you
got a bear root with me I didn't grow up
with this and I'm always like that's
fine Stan but you didn't grow up driving
and you figured it the [ __ ] out
the fact that you can grow up with this
is not an excuse
love that so for a lot of you that just
raised your hand there's a lot of things
or how do you edit a facebook video how
do you post this how to even place a
Facebook ad not all of you've done it
it's really simple I know a lot of you
have pads in front of you they game to
you this morning I'm going to give you a
website that will help you tremendously
through this journey if you want to
write it down it spelled G oh oh gee
it's called Google every single person
here basically I've been thinking about
this weird format of a keynote which is
I come out I say like the seven or eight
things that I think matter right now
Facebook video you know Instagram
hashtag culture a couple of other things
and then I basically say and now go to
Google and spend 10 hours on Google and
or YouTube for example Google wouldn't
work for me because I'm very bad at
reading I don't consume information that
way so then I would just go to youtube
and watch the you know YouTube by the
way is the second biggest search engine
in the world and so for a lot of you
that are more visual if you want to
figure out how to use snapchat or how to
use a 360 camera which would be a very
good idea for a lot of you here that are
listing that kind of content
Thank You Man 360 camera dude is here
and here sorry I go oh and right there
respect
nerd it up baby I love it I'm stunned by
the following statement that I think
rings very true in this room how many
people he actually you know what I'll
ask this question they'll make it a lot
better before I make the statement how
many people here are retiring in the
next 10 years and I don't mean you're
gonna crush it and retire
I mean you're old and you're finished so
great raise your hand if you're retiring
too young too young too young you're a
little bit older dude I see in the back
so for the four of you that are retiring
in the next ten years respect you can
take a lot of what I'm saying with a
grain of salt
I do think you might be able to hold on
for dear life and hold your breath right
for the rest of you I need to remind you
something 11 years ago
nothing that we talked about in society
existed not Netflix not YouTube not
smartphones not Facebook zero I hope you
understand that the biggest point of my
talk this morning is not go use that
hashtag or go make youtube videos it's
that if you are not digitally native you
will die and what I mean by that is
nothing you will die there like you'll
go directly out of business it's just
the people that are are gonna take your
business I look and by the way you know
what I'm most worried about good markets
a good year this year success that is my
enemy that is my enemy because you
become complacent it's tried and true
this works for me why the heck do I need
to figure out Facebook video why do I
have to figure out snapchat I'm good now
I'm the guy in my town I'm the 20 year
old lady that has dominated Rochester
New York [ __ ] Gary right like what you
know like like I don't need this I
understand the problem is and let's get
really humbled together real quick way
bigger businesses than you have been put
out of business because of technology
shifts borders was a bigger business
than yours right when I invested in uber
five years ago I called my dad's Russian
friends in LA and you know how many
people in the LA market great awesome so
a lot of you know a lot of the black car
service guys and gals over the last 20
years came from Eastern Europe Soviet
Union that that's where a lot of my
dad's homies came and we immigrated from
Russia
these are got think about this narrative
these are my dad's best friends now in
their 50s and 60s they came to this
country in 78 79 they were dead
they lived in studio apartments they
drove taxicabs for two three bucks an
hour hustled their way work every hour
no Saturday and Sunday for 20 years
built up a business didn't buy anything
saved all their money eventually bought
their own car eventually had four or
five guys or girls underneath them built
a business had the American Dream
finally got into their 50s and 60s
worked every goddamn minute to get there
and now we're going to kind of like
enjoy it a little bit and then uber came
along and so I called modoch and
Vladimir and these guys and said hey
Vladimir right now and said Vlad I've
got good news and bad news you know good
news is you know you've done well in
America is the greatest country in the
world bad news is you might be in
trouble and literally the three of them
verbatim we're all like that's nice boy
chick we'll be okay so what you're
telling me is they're gonna take a phone
and hit a button and the car is gonna
come very good very good I'll talk to
you later
you know the funny part is these are
very close friends of my family that's a
funny story and I say it funny here's
what's not funny every one of those
three guys businesses have been
slaughtered absolutely slaughtered all
of their businesses now that they're
trying to sell are literally worth 15
cents on the dollar of what it was worth
just four years ago the revenues have
been cut from high six figures to low
six figures even five figures they're
basically out of business nobody here is
super excited to go run and by an
independent black car service business
and so the one thing that I implore all
of you to understand is in a world where
the internet came along only 20 years
ago there's a lot of youngsters in this
room so pay very close attention
especially if you want to be in business
in 20 years only 20 years ago
windows 95 came out and finally got some
of us on the internet okay we're talking
about a very recent phenomenon I am very
confident that a lot of my venture
capital friends are going to lose a lot
of money betting on virtual reality
right now because it's too early but I'm
equally as confident
in 20 years we're going to be deeply
playing in a VR world a VR world that is
going to actually do to the Internet
what the internet did to real life
everything will reset because the only
thing that matters to this room is the
attention and if that attention means we
put on contact lenses and never take
them out and live in a world that is
virtual alongside with physical I think
more and more people here don't think
that is the most insane thing they've
ever heard I think more and more people
here especially if they're 45 50 60 70
remember how they judge the fad of the
internet and won't do the same thing
with VR I think a lot of people here
didn't expect people randomly running
through their backyard looking for
virtual Pikachu's and so I just really
want you to understand something I
basically look at this like a race I
think all of you are about to run a very
long marathon in business and the reason
I want you to be on snapchat is not
because I necessarily fully 1000%
believe that snapchats gonna change your
business it's that I need you to
understand how snapchat works because
that's like going on a treadmill and
getting prepared for the marathon nobody
here without training for it is just
gonna wake up tomorrow and run the New
York Marathon successfully if you are
not acting digitally every single day if
you are not understanding that all the
action all the opportunity is in the
people that draw lines in the sand and
say they're not going to do how about
this how many let's be very honest here
this is very important I want everybody
see this how many people in this room in
the last two or three years said that
they would never go on snapchat
it was stupid and now have snapchat
accounts raise your hand raise it
raising high raising high don't be
embarrassed it's a good thing raise it
high you need to understand in those
hands is where all the money is I'm
going to buy the New York Jets because
I'm really good at knowing what you say
you're not going to do and then no
you're gonna actually do it plenty of
people in this room especially if
they're over 45 said that they would
never get a cell phone
that their pager was good
a ton of you said you would never go on
Facebook 810 years ago why it was for
college kids and now you live in it
right we just saw 20 15 percent of this
room say they would never go on snapchat
and now there's t-shirts in the crowd
and on phone cases and it is a part of
our world
right 24 minutes ago it feels like
definitely two three days ago five days
ago for some of you that watch my vlog I
said that I was worried about
instagrams positioning in the
marketplace that it was getting squeezed
between snapchat and Facebook and then
out of nowhere I wake up and they make a
product feature change that competes
with snapchat and makes it dramatically
more relevant overnight this is a moving
marketplace I am actually thinking about
buying Drivetime radio ads for the first
time in 10 years because the price has
gone down so much that I'm now curious
if the ROI is there I'm not a digital or
a futurist I don't give a [ __ ] about
technology I care about your attention
because if I have your attention if I'm
good enough after that point I can sell
you something it's not confusing it's
not complicated the problem is it's hard
work the difference between the people
are going to win and lose here is far
less about talent it's going to be built
on two very simple tried-and-true
pillars that existed long before the
internet came along which is the
following two things it's a hundred
percent I can look at you one by one by
one and map your success based on two
very simple principles number one your
work ethic it's just going to matter you
know zero successful people that have
built it themselves that haven't put in
the work and number two the one that
almost everybody in this room is
struggling with and it's been the
absolute calling card of my career
patience the utter lack of patience in
this room is the absolute variable of
the people that win and lose especially
when we talk about the things that I
believe in like these platforms the
amount of people that have emailed me
and saying hey Gary
you got me super pumped on snapchat in
January well I've been really going at
it hard
and I'm not getting the results yet and
that email came in [ __ ] February the
amount of time it takes let me give you
a good example I think a lot of you can
agree because I know a lot of you know
me that I've been good at this stuff
that I've been good at this content and
social media thing for the last ten
years the day Facebook pages came out
for people the day it came out six seven
eight nine I'm trying to think about
eight years ago until four months ago
I've been putting out content every day
I've been Gary Vee I get plenty of
exposure pounding away doing everything
right and from that day eight years ago
to four months ago I am asked five
hundred fifty thousand likes followers
on my Facebook fan page in the last four
months that page has gone from five
hundred fifty thousand to over a million
followers organic because four months
ago I figured out how Facebook video was
working in a better way all those hours
my entire livelihood for seven years
running the biggest agency in the space
and I got to a half a million and in
four months an additional half a million
because chipping away and learning
chipping away and learning chipping away
and learning patience hard work patience
hard work and a huge game shift for my
business and my personal brand world
that is what it takes if you have the
audacity to sit here and want to have a
business on your terms and crush it and
live your life your way then you have to
put in the work into this craft because
there is so much of your consumers
attention living on it it is
unbelievable it is going to be the only
place to reach consumers it's funny the
reason I brought up Drivetime radio is
because again I'm just attention
arbitrage a right I've been running a
lot of direct mail who's running direct
mail here for their business raise your
hand I got to tell you if you're running
direct mail I don't know what you're
spending on your direct mail versus your
Facebook but I've been testing for Wine
Library very aggressively direct mail
for the last two years because I'm
always curious if my [ __ ] is real
right and then I've been looking at big
data for my big clients around their
couponing and things of that
sure I'm sitting here and telling you
today that Facebook is far better direct
mail than direct mail itself everything
you want Direct Mail to do is done 10
times better and half the price in a
facebook environment and again I didn't
close my thought earlier because I just
want to get into Q&A
are we doing Q&A thoughts or some Q&A
also there is great awesome
the reason I'm worried about my brands
Budweiser and Diageo and all these
brands coming into Facebook is that
five-cent word wine is now 9 dollars for
all of you that are running Facebook ads
and it costs you you know X Y is the
amount of dollars to reach a thousand
people and CPM to bring awareness to
your open house or your organization or
you as an agent that is going to cost
you five to twenty five times more than
it's costing you today in twenty four
months as last year was the biggest
decline in CPG consumer packaged goods
cereals toothpaste all that stuff last
year was the biggest decline in that
industry of all time because they spend
all their money on television and you're
not paying attention anymore when those
characters figure out that they need to
spend more money in this world it's not
like one more agent here decides to do
it and they're gonna spend five thousand
bucks and it doesn't really become that
much more competitive it's that a
company goes like Macy's Macy's one from
a million dollars to fifty million
dollars spent in facebook this last year
right when you have the other fortune
500 to do that you're going to be wiped
out of the feed you're not gonna be able
to afford the ads that can drive your
business right now and so I don't want
you to sit with the regret that I have
you've heard my story of Wine Library
three to sixty million
let me tell you the great regret of my
career that story should be three to
four hundred million let me tell you why
it's not because when I had Google
AdWords really working for me I wasn't
smart enough to go all-in when it was
five cents a click
I didn't maximize all the people I could
had I was still buying print I was still
buying radio I was still doing a lot of
direct mail
I was doing local television commercials
I was doing event marketing I was doing
a mix what I should have done and what
I'm doing with Facebook now for my
clients is I'm going pot committed when
something is grossly underpriced in
attention you strike and that is what
we're living through right now in a
facebook environment and I think you
guys know me well enough I'm giving this
advice right now not because I love you
so much
but because d-roc is filming this and I
can't wait to run this in three years
and say I [ __ ] told you and so please
please please if nothing else if this is
your business and your livelihood are
you telling me that you don't have five
hours to go home after this conference
and read every article and watch every
video of how to run great Facebook ads
and make creative you don't have that
time you don't have that time for your
business are you kidding me
so please please please become
disproportionally educated on what's
going on there number two figure out the
following thing how do you become a
media company because that is the
absolute only way that you can actually
double or triple your business you may
not be as extroverted as me or the next
person so maybe it's not even video
maybe it's the written word maybe it's
some other communication style maybe
it's radio podcasting podcasting is app
how many people here listening to
podcasts raise your hands it's real it's
happening so you don't need a national
podcast have a local podcast because the
funny part is it's not about how many
followers you have it's about how many
followers you need to buy something you
don't need a million people listening to
your podcast if you have all 37,000 of
the town that you are selling within
you've won you're gonna win and so we
are just not thinking about the
opportunities in the marketplace in a
significant enough way we are living
through the single biggest cultural
shift of our time because I promise you
something right now for all of you that
dude back there respect but only four of
you are retiring in 10 years what do you
think somebody that's 22 right now is
going to be doing when they decide to
buy their home in 10 years
how do you think they're gonna act what
do you think they're gonna get their
information from how is it gonna roll
and by the way the punchline is it's the
same tried and true [ __ ] that's going on
now
it's word of mouth it's word of mouth so
many of you do business on word of mouth
but the important part is that cell
phone the internet that is the
infrastructure of word of mouth in our
society today 20 years ago when somebody
did a good job for you sold your home
boy your home
served you a nice cup of coffee whatever
it was 20 years ago when somebody did
something great you told one or two of
your girlfriends or homies today we feel
compelled to share every one of our
[ __ ] thoughts on social media right
that is very important for this room and
what you need to be doing tomorrow is
producing a disproportionate amount of
content and distributing it everywhere
some of them will work some of them
won't but here's the punchline my
friends
the wasted time that I put into vine and
Socialcam was the reason that I
dominated on snapchat and Instagram
video the things I learned on those
platforms mapped to the next thing so
while you sit in your seats here and
ponder is it worth your time or my
favorite well will snapchat be around in
two years who gives a [ __ ] it's around
right now no advertising company worried
if friends or Seinfeld was going to be
cancelled in two or three years they
cared while everybody's attention was on
it
they ran commercials it's not up to you
to decide where society should be you
know what I love about business people
agents marketers people that run their
businesses they feel like their personal
point of view on the world is how they
should be running their business I'm
sorry that you're upset that all our
kids are on technology I love my modern
parents now you know now I'm seven year
old and a four year old so I've got a
lot of parent friends right and I love
to go out to dinner with Lizzy and I and
say oh and they know what I do
oh this technology is really shitty it's
ruining our kids
like Rick that's super cool but the last
two times I hung out with you when
little Jake got really up buddy and kind
of crazy you threw that [ __ ] iPad at
him so fast he couldn't even move and
you guys loved to go into a restaurant
walk in and see a couple and both of
them are on the phone the whole time and
you love to save your partner look how
sad that is right
isn't that so sad when I see that I
think it's the greatest thing I've ever
seen let me tell you why that same
couple ten years ago when they didn't
have their cell phones they just sat
there in front of each other and didn't
say a [ __ ] word their marriage was
[ __ ] the phone didn't do it and so I'm
just happy for them because they're
actually doing what they want to be
doing right so I understand how you
don't want it to be but Lemery let me
remind you this your grandmother thought
Elvis shaking his hips was the devil a
lot of us grew up in a world where they
didn't want us playing Zelda and Mike
Tyson's punch-out because we were gonna
get ruined yet a lot of our
contemporaries mainly the kids younger
than us are making five to ten million
dollars a year playing video games the
world changes and the biggest part that
I'm worried about is the world is
changing in a much bigger way that you
and/or I realize and you need to make a
religious decision here today not a
tactical one this isn't about signing up
for snapchat when Gary gets off the
stage this is about a binary decision of
are you understanding how important
digital is or are you not and more
importantly making your actions map your
words thank you
Thank You summer and
thank you
thank you so much
thank you so much
thank you
thank you so much
do we have time for Q&A or do I lose my
time what happened we got a couple let's
do it
who's got a question who's got them
doing mics are we going ghetto Sal let's
go get our stuff go ahead I'll repeat
the question really good Michael
appreciate it yes thank you
yes they're saying you're spending all
this time Michael just spend all this
time and snapchat and now you got
Instagram stories coming out you're dead
you're [ __ ] yeah all that scary scary
stuff I'm I'm excited about a new
opportunity yeah but my question to you
is there is obviously only so much time
in a day and I've always been told you
should also focus real quick I mad with
these two things yes there's only so
much time in a day but Sally who's
thinking about buying a home wants to
watch Instagram stories and Rick who
wants to buy a home is watching snapchat
stories yeah like how is this
complicated like have you guys not just
lived through everybody saying Facebook
was dead for the last three years cuz
it's not young anymore and it's the
single best [ __ ] ad product in the
world my man the answer is both now now
it's important to be smart for example I
believe that Instagram stories is very
powerful for a lot of people in here
because snapchat skews a little bit
younger and everybody's gonna default
into thinking here is if I'm gonna sell
an eight hundred thousand dollar home
it's more likely going to be a forty
two-year-old than a twenty four-year-old
and I think there's some validity to
that so Instagram stories is something I
think every single person should do here
because I think it will 100% work to
sell a home today snapchat is something
every single person should do here
because I think it's a platform person
snapshots gonna be a virtual refuse me
an augmented reality platform all the AR
companies they're buying the way they do
filters snapchats doing a lot of other
things and again you know I don't know
like the young and wealthy uncertainty
depends on your market if you're in
Kansas and I love York City Gary what's
that New York
with you yeah I mean if you're in New
York City you have to do snapchat
snapchat New York City is 45 and under
you know there's obviously middle parts
of America and other places where it's
skews younger you just have to look at
your data but the answer is both and
focus stop [ __ ] watching [ __ ]
Netflix and do both I love when people
like I've been taught to focus and I
look at their day and they work six
hours a day between their [ __ ]
hour-and-a-half lunch then bullshitting
in the morning to like talk to everybody
[ __ ] checking YouTube 13 times a day
for four minutes each I'm like focus
[ __ ] work right Oh both questions you
want to yeah take it wherever you want
Gary thanks for the time bill inhale out
of Raleigh North Carolina I'm still
hitting doors yes home to home I love it
not gonna get me off it thank you how
about real quick sure what's your name
again
Dylan Hale villain while you're walking
up to the [ __ ] door I feel like knock
on it
yeah you could be knocking on the door
here and knocking on it
yeah that's my question how to
incorporate social media and modern
media marketing to maximize that I'm
being dead serious
yeah you know a lot of people know that
I hold on to it that I engage a ton I'm
gay I'm busy every minute when I get up
from my desk to go to the bathroom I
open my phone and engage with three
people on Twitter or I make a piece of
content that's on my mind right so
literally I'm being dead serious that
wasn't a joke when you get out of your
car and you walk and you go to knock in
between those two minutes
like in that 39 seconds either produce
content or engaged with the small
community that you've started building
I'm putting out some content there
here's me hitting doors in this new
neighborhood a targeting type of thing
specifically how do I engage that person
that I've just made a contact with so
that they're connected to me you mean we
mean the person on the guy talk to this
is yeah I'm thinking about selling my
house on the knock
yeah um door that guy I would get a cell
phone number okay like yeah if you know
what I mean like I would be like hey
give me your cell and I would text him
like that is the most intimate
relationship in technology today no
here's giving their cellphone out for
text marketing because it's the one
protective place we have if I were you I
would get many of them into my into the
text I would take a picture of their
door and like have that as their image
so you could keep track and that's what
I would do
fair enough thank on it you're welcome I
got to run they're kicking me off I'm
sorry love you guys
thank you
[Music]